so we have some data here that we can
plot on a scatter plot that looks
something like that
and so the next question given that
we've been talking a lot about lines of
regression or regression lines is can we
fit a regression line to this
well if we try to we might get something
that looks like
this
or maybe something that looks like this
i'm just eyeballing it obviously we
could input it into a computer to try to
develop a linear regression model to try
to minimize the sum of the squared
distances from the points to the line
but you can see it's pretty difficult
and some of you might be saying well
this looks more like some type of an
exponential so maybe we could fit an
exponential to it so it could look
something
like that and you wouldn't be wrong
but there is a way that we can apply our
tools of linear regression to this data
set and the way we can is instead of
plotting x versus y we can think about x
versus the logarithm of y
so this is this is exact same data set
you see the x values are the same but
for the y values i just took the log
base 10 of all of these so 10 to the
what power is equal to 2307.23
10 to the 3.36 power is equal to
2307.23 and i did that for all of these
data points i did it on a spreadsheet
and if you were to plot all of these
something neat happens
all of a sudden when we're plotting x
versus the log of y or the log of y
versus x all of a sudden it looks linear
now be clear the true relationship
between x and y is not linear it looks
like some type of an exponential
relationship but the value of
transforming the data and there's
different ways you can do it in this
case the value of taking the log of y
and thinking about it that way is now we
can use our tools of linear regression
because this data set you could actually
fit a linear regression line to this
quite well you could imagine a line that
looks something
like this it would fit the data quite
well
and the reason why you might want to do
this versus trying to fit an exponential
is because we've already developed so
many tools around linear regression and
hypothesis testing around the slope and
confidence intervals and so this might
be the direction you want to go at and
what's neat is once you fit a linear
regression it's not difficult to
mathematically unwind from your linear
model back to an exponential one so the
big takeaway here is is that the tools
of linear regression can be useful even
when the underlying relationship between
x and y are non-linear and the way that
we do that is by transforming the data
here we took a logarithm of the y's and
that helped us see a more linear
relationship of log y versus x